hi um
welcome everybody um my name is cara
parger and i am an associate professor
at the university at old albany in
upstate new york um i am also
associated with the rna institute so i'm
really excited to give this talk to you
today to tell you about rna
modifications
and particularly how they can actually
end up changing
during a viral infection but also the
amazing thing is that these
modifications are also found on cells
these modifications are also found on
the viral rna
all right
so
if i take you
um just go back here so what i'm going
to do this afternoon is that i'm
essentially going to cover four things
so first is i'm just going to give you a
quick overview of modifications on dna
and protein as a way of a preface
for talking about rna modifications
and then i'm going to tell you about how
these modifications are actually
detected and the strategy that we use to
detect modifications and then lastly i'm
going to share with you some data that
we have a little bit of it is published
some of it is unpublished um
looking at rna modifications during zika
virus infection
so if i take you to the central dogma
right we know that we have our genetic
material that is encoded in our dna
from there we can get mrna that is
transcribed and this mrna acts as a
messenger to produce your proteins
now if i asked you this question
right is there a cipher or a code that
regulates biological molecules
you probably already think of maybe one
or two possible codes
so the first is the epigenetic code
right so this is
modifications that are occurring on
histones and these can be modifications
such as a methyl group or an acetyl
group a phosphorylation group or even a
simulation group that is on the histones
and what this does is that it either
allows the
modified as the dna to be more compact
associated with
the
histones or to loosen it up so that you
can now have a transcriptionally active
region inside of the dna
all right so the second type of
modification would be
perhaps one that you thought of as that
is the modifications that are on
proteins and here we actually have got a
plethora of modifications
um and these modifications are really
important for
localizing a protein to a particular
area for regulating whether a protein is
turned on or turned off
as well as its specific interactions
with different types of proteins
so
if i come back to the slide
you've probably thought about
the um
cipher or codes that are on dna and
proteins
but what about rna and so that's really
what i'm going to be telling you about
today
so
if you think about rna you're familiar
with the four canonical nucleotides
right adenine guanine cytogene and
uridine
so when i'm talking about modification
what's what i'm talking about are
chemical marks that are placed on the
rna
so here i'm giving you an example
of five different types of modifications
that are on
adenosine so one is this methyl group
that is placed on the ribose sugar
or you can have methyl groups that are
placed on the nucleotide base the
nitrogenous base over here
so here you've got one methyl adenosine
two
2-methyladenosine
n6
m6 methyl adenosine and here you have
even got two methyl groups placed on the
nitrogenous base
the one thing i want to point out to you
here is that here i am showing you just
five
modifications on one nucleotide
what you might not or might not what you
might or might not realize is that there
are actually more than 140 modifications
in fact in some databases they even list
more than 170 different modifications
i mean this is just really mind-blowing
so if you're thinking to yourself like
wow so many modifications
what are these modifications doing
well the truth is for a lot of them we
actually don't really understand what
they do
but for some of those i'm going to share
with you a little bit about what they do
now
if we look at an mrna over here there is
a modification that's been known since
the 70s and
here this is the modification that is on
the beginning of an mrna or the
7-methylguanosine cap
such as i've shown you over here now
this cap is really important to a
messenger rna
why is it important
well
it's important because if that rna is
not capped it's not going to be exported
out of the nucleus
that cap is important for stabilizing
the rna
but what is also really important for is
for translation
so that's one modification
what about another modification
so another one that i'm going to
introduce you to
is this
m6a or n6 methyl adenosine
so
the way that these modifications are put
on to rna they can be dynamic in that
you can have particular enzymes that
actually install the modifications and
these enzymes are known as writers and
for m6a we actually know what those
writers are
let's say these some of these
modifications are dynamic so they can
also be removed and here we have erasers
that are able to move them
so
you've got these enzymes that put them
on and take them off but
what about proteins that actually help
with a particular function
well these proteins are known as readers
and for m6a we actually know that there
are a number of different readers and
what these readers do is that they
actually help
give function to that particular
modification so for instance m6a can
influence alternative splicing
it can influence the export of the rna
out of the cell
as well as the stability so some rnas
that have got this modification on them
when they're associated with the reader
will actually be processed and sent to
the processing body where you get rna
turnover
now this one modification over here the
m1a or n1 methyl adenosine this
modification we know is important for
translation
but now i'm going to remind you about
the fact
that there are 170 different
modifications so keep that in mind
now i've shown you about rna
modifications that are on cellular rnas
right so i've shown you three examples
but what about viral rnas well it
actually turns out that we have known
about rna modifications in part because
of viruses so that modification of the
cat the m7g
we've known about because of vaccinia
virus and rio virus
now this one modification m6a which i
keep referring to
is a modification that is really well
characterized
and we've known about this modification
again since the late 70s and early 80s
because it was already identified on
simian virus 40 mrna
influenza virus mrna and rao sarcoma
virus rna
so even though this modification was
identified in the early 70s or late 70s
the renaissance of this particular
modification and really the functional
impact came about from studies that were
published in 2016 from tarek rana's lab
where he beautifully showed that this
one particular modification this m6a on
hiv
was really important for exporting the
rna out of the nucleus
now one thing that you might or might
not realize about the four examples of
viruses i've given you is that all four
of these viruses their life cycle is
actually in the nucleus
so what about rnas or viruses that
replicate in the cytoplasm can these be
modified
because i just showed you on the
previous slide that modifications occur
in the nucleus so what about them
well there was actually some really
beautiful studies that were done from um
uh
stacy horner's lab at duke and she
showed that
hepatitis c or hcv can also be modified
with this m6a modification and this
modification is really important for the
packaging of the viral rna into virions
as well as for regulating the innate
immune response but we also know for
viruses like zika virus dengue virus
yellow fever virus these viruses have
also harbored this m6a modification
but again i'm going to remind you that
there are more than 140 modifications so
what are these other modifications doing
well the first thing is that if we want
to identify a modification or a chemical
group on an rna how do we go about doing
this
well there are a couple of strategies
um
and
the first three strategies really are
relying on identifying a very particular
type of rna modification so the first
one is there are actually antibodies out
there that will detect a rna
modification
and so here i'm showing you a
northwestern block that my student
rachel netspend did
and it's looking at um
rna
that is from uninfected cells or cells
infected with dengue and then she used
this antibody against m6a
and if you look carefully you can see
that there are some bands here in the
viral rna
or they're present in the uninfected
cells
so
this m6a antibody has been very
successfully used to identify
modification that particular
modification on cellular rnas
and the way that it works is that people
will isolate rna they will then chop it
up into fragments use that antibody to
selectively pull out
rna that harbors that particular
modification and then they'll use next
generation sequencing analysis to try
and pinpoint where that modification is
this technique has been used um used
with identifying
one methyl methyladenosine
five methylcytosine pseudouridine four
meal cytosine and four acetylcytazine
there's another way in which we can do
this and this is a very similar type of
approach but instead of using an
antibody one will actually use a
chemical and this will land up modifying
the um what is the group that is on that
particular nucleotide which you can then
differentiate when you do rna sequencing
analysis
the third way to do this is that you can
actually run out the
nucleotides on bison layer
chromatography and then if you've got
particular um
if you've got particular standards you
can now actually identify
what modifications you've got
now the thing about these three types of
methods is that you either need a
standard or you need a reagent
so how are you going to go about
identifying these 140 other
modifications
well the strategy that you can use
is one that is an unbiased detection
right and this is mass spectrometry and
this is the technique that we use in my
lab
so just briefly i'm going to give you an
introduction is that my lab studies
hepatitis c
zika virus and dengue virus and we're
really interested in how these viruses
subvert the host rna pathways
and of course today i'm telling you
about how these viruses use rna
modifications
and the particular virus i'm going to
tell you about
is actually zika virus this is a virus
that was first identified in 1947
in the zika forest in uganda
and for the most part those virus when
people are infected with it they have
mild symptoms
but in 2015 and 2016 we had an outbreak
in the americas
um and
this outbreak was associated with
neurological and
developmental defects in newborns and
adults were also developing
guillain-barre syndrome
we know from um
from this outbreak that
zika virus is trans primarily
transmitted by mosquitoes but it can
also be transmitted sexually
and to date we have got very limited
treatment options so
understanding the fundamentals
is really important
all right now i'm going to come back to
our mass spectrometry
how do we actually do this well what we
do is we take our cells that are either
uninfected
or we take cells that are infected and
we isolate total rna
what we then do is we use exonucleases
and we digest the long rna into the
mononucleotides
from there we use direct infusion
electrospray ionization
and then we get our mass spectrum and if
you have a look on
the x-axis you see the m over z values
and on the y-axis you've got the
relative abundance and immediately
you'll see four very high peaks and
these high peaks they correspond to the
four canonical bases
c u a and g
and then the u could also be
pseudo-uridine
but if you look much much lower down
there are small little peaks there and
those peaks are the ones that correspond
to rna modifications
so what we do is we take those small
peaks
and we then
generate a math list
from this math list
we then do our database searches and we
compare against three different
databases
and we identify our putative heads and
what we do is we then take our pieces of
heads and we go back
and we confirm them and so we either do
this by tandem spectrometry where we
take the nucleotide and we fragment it
further
or we do it by iron mobility where we
look at how this particular
molecule tumbles in a vacuum
and that will then tell us what
modification we have so the data i'm
going to show you
we
represent in a way that my students
refer to as a skittles plot
and really what it is is just a really
bright colored table
and so
what we have is at the very top we list
the number of modifications we
identified
on the left column we list um the
modifications that um
that we detected or didn't detect
and if you've got two modifications on
the same line what this means is that
they are isoboric so they've got the
same m over as each value
and then we've got this color gradient
and what this color gradient
represents is a relative abundance and
so we refer to this as abundance versus
proxy or avp
and essentially what we're doing is
we're taking the intensity of the small
peaks and we're dividing it by the
intensity of the sum of the four
canonical bases
so the sum of the four canonical bases
lands up being our internal reference or
our proxy and then we times it by a
hundred so we get a percentage
so if you've got warm colors that what
that means is that that modification is
approaching one percent
pseudo-uridine is in a much higher is
much higher than one percent and so we
actually introduced a grayscale
and if you go towards the cooler colors
this represents a much lower abundance
we do this with five biological
replicates and five runs each so that we
get ready to type statistics
if you see a white
box what this means is that we didn't
identify that particular modification
all right so what we did right is we
took ourselves and then we either mock
infected them so no virus
or we infected them with zika virus
and this is what we found
all right we found in our uninfected
cells we identified 47 different rna
modifications
but in our zika virus infected cells we
identified 44 different modifications
so immediately you can see that there
are some trends here
so first there are some modifications
that disappear during virus infection
there are some modifications that don't
disappear but they do decrease in
intensity
there are other modifications that
increase in intensity
and then there was one particular
modification that we were very excited
to identify is actually this
dimethyl cytosine modification
so this is
um
the five two primo methyl dimethyl
cytosine or n4n4 dimethyl cytosine and
what was really interesting is that this
particular modification we also
identified during other viral infections
all right so this is looking at just
zika virus infection in mammalian cells
and if you think back to a couple of
slides ago one of the things that i told
you is that zika virus can actually be
transmitted by mosquitoes
so just as a reminder in the forest
mosquitoes may end up
infecting
apes and so this is how the mosquito or
the the zika virus infectious cycle is
transmitted and maintained
if there is some spillover and a
mosquito will infect a human this human
can then actually end up propagating the
virus through what we refer to as the
urban cycle
where we've either got our aedes aegypti
or 80s ultra pictures as being the
viruses that are responsible for
transmitting
this virus
so
we asked the question was how does the
post-transcriptional
rna modification landscape change
between mammalian and mosquito hosts
during zika virus infection
to answer this question what we did is
that in collaboration with alexiota at
wattsworth which is new york state labs
we infected aedes aegypti mosquitos with
zika virus so what we did was that we
gave the mosquitoes a blood meal that
was either just a blood meal or a blood
meal that had zika virus in it
the mosquitoes were allowed to feed for
30 minutes
and then we separated those out
the mosquitoes that had blood in their
bellies versus those that hadn't fed
we waited two weeks and then we
collected the mosquitoes
what we did was that we took the
mosquitoes um that were either mock
infected or infected with zika virus put
them into a small tube homogenize them
with a bb
and then did a trisol extraction to
harvest the rna
we did qpcr to identify whether the
mosquitoes were indeed infected or
whether they were uninfected and then we
did mass spec
so in total what we had is that we had
32 different
mosquitoes that were
mock infected and 39 that had been
infected with zika virus
so if we now go back to our skittles
plot
which i'm showing you here
again what we've got is we've got the
rna modifications that we identified in
this first column
then we've got our 32 mosquitoes that
were mock infected all the 39 mosquitoes
that were infected with zika virus
where each column represents one
particular
mosquito
so
this table is overwhelming
and i will show you some more pyradine
on the next slide
but one of the reasons that i like
showing it is that you really do get an
appreciation for the variability that
there is between different organisms
right from one mosquito to the next
but if you look carefully you can see
there are some trends for instance these
um this area over here you see that
you're now detecting some modifications
that you didn't identify earlier
this one over here you've now got more
of that particular modification
so if we take all of these modifications
and we actually collapse them down
what we find is that if we look at the
modifications on the x-axis versus the
abundance
the abundance versus proxy on the y-axis
what we immediately notice is that
during
zika virus infection we see this
increase in the number of nucleotides
that have been monomethylated
so this means that they have got a
methyl group either on the nitrogenous
base or on the ribose sugar
and then this quickly drops off for the
other modifications
so
up until now i've shown you rna in terms
of the whole cell
what about can the viral rna be modified
well i already told you that m6a or n6
methyladenosis had been identified on
the viral rna
what we wanted to know was what about
those other modifications
and so to do this
what we did is we used an affinity
capture approach
where we isolated rna we then annealed
antisense by attenuated oligonucleotides
to specifically pull out
viral rna which we were able to do
through a streptavidin bead we then
eluted and we did our mass spec
so here i'm showing you the data in a
little bit of a different form but it
shows you really nicely that there is a
difference between rna of viral rna that
was isolated inside of the cell
versus rna that was isolated from
virions that had been released from the
cell
so what i've got on the x-axis is we've
got the particular types of
modifications on the y-axis we've got
the abundance versus proxy
so for the viruses inside of the cell we
identified 32 different modifications
for rna that had been packaged into
virions we identified 41 different
modifications
what was gratifying is that we
identified 30 modifications between the
two groups but we also identified that
m6a modification that had been
previously found the m7g which was
important because we know that the viral
rna has a cap
what we also identified is that there
are some modifications that are unique
to the intracellular rna
and then there are modifications that
are also unique to the viral rna that
has been released from the cell
and here again we saw that that dimethyl
cytosine species that we identified
only on the um
only during viral infection was now
present on zika virus rna that have been
released from the cell so it's
tantalizing to hypothesize that maybe
this particular type of modification is
there as a signal again that this rna
should be packaged into viral capsid and
be released from the cell
so what have i told you today i hope
that you will take away from this is
that rna can be modified for chemical
groups and there are so many different
modifications out there
the other is that the type of
modification will actually influence the
function and you can have many different
types of functions as a result of those
particular modifications
but from the data i showed you
is that during viral infection when you
have something perturbing the cellular
homeostasis
that causes a dramatic change in the rna
modification landscape but what's even
more exciting
is that the viral rna is modified and
it's not just modified with an m7g cap
or one modification it can have upwards
of 30 or 40 different rna modifications
on the viral rna
and so this then brings the question
like well what next where do we go from
here
well
what ultimately what we want to know is
what are these modifications doing
during viral infection
so one way we can ask the question is to
say well
let's think about those enzymes that are
responsible for either putting on the
modification
removing the modification or
interpreting the function right and
contributing to it so if we know what
those enzymes are we can potentially
manipulate the system and then ask
what happens
do we now see an effect on the virus
infection
the second way would be to identify
where those modifications are within the
viral genome and then go in and mutate
those particular sites and ask more what
is the consequence and these are all
really terrific ideas but they're
actually really challenged when it comes
to um looking at rna modifications
for one we've got very few um reagents
such as antibodies or chemicals that we
can modify the rna
um and for a lot of these modifications
we don't really know what the enzymes
are
so this is an incredibly exciting field
with lots to explore um
but also faced with some challenges that
my lab is really excited about um
undertaking
so last um i just want to highlight um
this is my lab over here from halloween
last year and um the person who did most
of the work was rachel nessband and um
gaston bonin fund
a in my collaborative lab dan cyboris
will mcintyre also contributed
at wadsworth and alex yota's lab sean
was also contributing towards the
mosquito work and of course i want to
thank our funding sources as well as our
collaborators for other res for reagents
thank you very much